and then one more from faye divorce
shack
what books or movies have had an impact
on the way you think about things
what was going on in your life at the
time that you read or saw them and how
did they change your thinking
oh wow i don't know about some of that
that's deep
what books or movies you know i like
that movie uh
bridges of madison county
you know there's just a moment of choice
in there a moment of love a moment of
comfort you know
it just shows how people's lives can
interact and they're not really
you know how every decision you make
isn't so
well it just shows that you can get love
in different places and that there's
different levels to love and different
parts of love some love you get from
here and some love you get from there
so i like that movie bridges of madison
county and it's about bridges man
bridges you know
because think about this before bridge
is what people had to try and
jump over something
so if you wanted to get a message to
somebody
across the whatever water
you know or whatever dragon area
you had to [ __ ] get a buddy
feed him a bunch of stakes and
everything train him
you know get him a rosary couple
rosaries
you know tell him he was gonna make it
and then send him out there running
and the dragon got him and i'm saying so
bridges are everything
bridges are really because before that
you had to get wet or get eaten or get
burnt i mean bridges
name you know name 11 other things
that are better than that
over time maybe and you know and
everybody did a bridge
that wasn't just you know benjamin
franklin hogging all the uh
um you know ob
frankie hogging all the damn
inventions everybody did a bridge ben
so sorry i shouldn't got upset about
that but that [ __ ] kind of
you know a lot of times all these old
people they just put you know
you know einstein
[ __ ] who else what's that guy's name
uh miserac steve mizerak
um yeah all these people say they
invented everything thomas jefferson
tj and oh yeah you guys did it all
but no everybody did bridges good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one